this is a production of Cornell
University
okay hi
I'm Silva Hansen I'm excited to talk
with you all today about uh
participatory plant breeding and to get
a chance to be a part of the Cornell
plant science Community
um so today I'm going to talk to you
about participatory plant breeding and
variety trialing which are themes that
have connected my doctoral and
postdoctoral work in vegetable breeding
and that I now get to explore in my
current role with the cover crop reading
Network
so by way of introduction I've passed to
plant breeding started on the land I
grew up in Southwest Wisconsin
um where my Norwegian and German
ancestors settled in the mid to late
1800s on on Ho Chunk land
I was an outdoor kid I still am
I went to college and caught the organic
farming bug and then I spent eight
seasons as co-owner of a direct Market
vegetable farm in Northeast Iowa
for me farming tied together
environmental care working outside
business and marketing and caring for my
community I I saw it as a way to put
ethics into action and ethics into
tangible even edible form
but after selling that Farm after about
eight years I moved to Western New York
I got a job at Harris seeds up in
Rochester New York as organic product
manager
as a farmer I had
known
I'd observed the difference between
varieties and that a choice
the choice of variety made a lot of
difference in how well my farm was going
to do that year but as a product manager
I got to observe these differences
systematically
I didn't
however know how these differences came
about
but then came an organic plant breeding
Workshop in 2012 where I heard
um
folks including professors here at
Cornell
um
describe population creation selection
reproductive biology and I started to
think maybe this is something I could
learn also
so I made some contacts at University of
Wisconsin
um and
long story short ended up earning a
doctorate in uh in a beach breeding with
Dr Irwin Goldman at um at University of
Wisconsin and then I went on to do a
postdoc in participatory professional
breeding at UBC
foreign
before starting my plant breeding
stories I'm just going to take a beat to
recognize that I've
um
farmed and done research on the
ancestral traditional lands and
coercively acquired lands of many
different indigenous groups
land acknowledgments have gotten have
been aptly critiqued for being
perfunctory or performative
but I do think it's appropriate just to
hold the space to acknowledge that seed
as a way of literally making space on
the land for the people who eat those
crops and the farming systems that grow
those crops to
um
to sustain themselves
and that seed is used as a tool of
control and colonization even as it's
also used as a tool of sustenance
um so I'm just going to invite us to
hold that in awareness and to
hold an awareness who and what we're
making room for on the land when we do
our work
early in my plant breeding journey I
heard Bill Tracy was a farm breeder at
Wisconsin
uh talk about plant breeding as
conversation a multi-species
conversation most obviously between
humans and crop plants but with input
from the many other species that compose
an agro ecosystem
so this conversational Motif captured my
imagination and reminded me of my
experiences as a farmer where I'm
learning my land by trial and error by
my asking a question and getting an
answer from my land about what it could
do with what I was giving it
so when I learned that participatory
plant breeding was not just a concept
but a field with a literature and
researchers and practitioners I knew
that this was something I wanted to get
involved in so today I'm going to tell
two stories uh a participatory beat
reading story a participatory variety
trialing story and then talk about
possibilities for ways we can use these
techniques to um
to enhance
covering networks understanding of the
crops we're working with and help
Advance varieties toward farmer adoption
so participatory plant breeding is a
crop development strategy that
facilitates farmer-involved selection in
environments that diverge from
conventional plant breeding environments
it was developed in the global South
um with Farmers cultivating marginal
land but it's been adapted widely for
use in the global North specifically for
Farmers using organic and low input
practices so it facilitates
um
direct selection in the Target
environment which is often an organic or
low input environment instead of
indirect selection in a conventional
environment which in certain cases and
for certain traits can lead to better
response to selection for complex traits
like yield climatic adaptation and
flavor
ppv allows for marketing to start while
cultivars are being developed and it
also allows for Creative space and
relationships to build that can pay
dividends both during and after the
breeding process
participatory breeding projects take a
lot of different shapes uh there's a new
review of ppb in the global North by
Michaela Kali and she notes that
agronomic crop Improvement is only one
reason that people use participatory
techniques folks want to they may want
to preserve prep genetic diversity they
might want to pursue seed sovereignty or
seed security goals
or they might want to more closely
control the breeding techniques that are
used
my first story
is about beets and it's going to require
a little bit of background on beet
flavor
which is coming now
[Laughter]
reference for table beef is very
Divergent my favorite thing about
working on table beat is that upon
learning such many people would tell me
that they love beats or hated beets
there hasn't been a lot of systematic
study of a holistic beet flavor but it's
generally agreed that sweet earthy
bitter and harsh attributes are are
present in beat and each associated with
one or several compounds
the earthy flavor is the one most
associated with preference or
non-preference for me so people think
beets are dirt candy or that they just
taste like dirt
earthy flavor and beat is conferred by G
Osmond this 12 carbon volatile molecule
which is synthesized by a wide variety
of soil microbes
it is the scent of freshly turned Earth
and it can be present in water and a
variety of different foods but it's
usually recognized as a contaminant
humans are very sensitive to this
molecule more so than many others
and a study that's almost as old as I am
connected Jasmine
earthy Aroma and the perception of quote
signature beet flavor
and So based on based on these
assumptions that Jasmine is present
people think beets are earthy and people
either do or don't like that earthy
flavor
um my lab at the University of Wisconsin
decided to investigate the um
the origin and genetic control of
geosmin and table B I could talk for a
long time about that but we are going to
cut to the chase
Yasmine is heritable and endogenously
produced by beep instead of being
absorbed by beet from the soil
environment
so despite the low resolution this
figure shows two two qtl two large
effect qtl for
um associated with GSM concentration in
table B
we've also shown Jasmine heritability in
both GB studies and this recurrent
selection experiment but this recurrent
selection experiment
um
dividend and that it produced these cool
beat populations with both extreme
geosmin concentration and segregating
color
so I looked at these and thought this is
a cool population for participatory
selection because it's that unique
flavor and it's got unique color and
both of those things are engaging
so the participatory beat breeding
project sought to develop some specialty
cultivars for particularly particularly
relevant in the organic and direct
Market uh Farm sector
and to gauge Jasmine preference in
non-laboratory conditions so I ran two
models and they each had three groups of
selectors so a farm group that would
select for Horticultural characteristics
and then two groups of hedonic selection
participants or people who told me how
much they like to eat the beets
um within the farm model all these
people were associated with a single
Farm south of Madison
and then in the Outreach model
all of the group that I took a survey of
farmers about two dozen farmers and then
both chefs and consumers convened by the
seed to Kitchen collaborative
um helped with this hedonic selection
and that's a program of the UW Court
department specifically Julie Dawson's
program
the first two cycles of participatory
selection followed this model
you'll see that it started with 30 half
of families of either high or low
Jasmine character that families were
eliminated at each step leaving which
I'll say more about in a bit
leaving five families to intermate and
create seed for the Next Generation
to guide Horticultural selection uh
Farmers rated the importance of various
traits on a one through five scale on a
survey or just in a conversation with
Steve Pincus The Farmer in the photo
um
Farmers indicated not unexpectedly that
high germination ability to out-compete
weeds and disease resistance were top
priorities uh for selection so I made a
selection index that waited traits by
farmer uh by farmer priority and then
also added qualitative comments
so using farmer priorities and and uh my
comments
a third of the families were eliminated
the remaining families I sorted into
groups based on their visual appearance
and then my hedonic selection
participants uh went to work I presented
all four groups to the core the core
group of selectors so that was chefs in
the Outreach model and Farm staff in the
farm model they narrowed it down to two
then I presented the last one to the
consumer group and they picked their
their favorite thing to be Advanced to
the Next Generation
we didn't find any uh any differences
between like in liking between high and
low geosman groups taken in aggregate
which is interesting given that um G
Osmond and earthy flavor have been have
a were assumed to play a role in
preference or non-preference for B
we did find two big disparities in
liking and that was around appearance
and those came when we compared a white
bead group to a pigmented feed group so
on the order of 25 of people liking the
white group and about 80 percent liking
the pigmented group
but after trying them those differences
evened out they were both equally liked
suggesting that a favorable flavor made
up for this difference in in appearance
liking so this is interesting
um
in studies of expectation
um well
food with low color is often associated
with it with an expectation of low
flavor and if that happened here
um this would be a positive
disconfirmation of expectations or
getting more than you thought you would
which people like so that could explain
some of this phenomenon we saw
um notably both of these groups were
selected by chefs both of the groups
were acted by chefs whose job is to
create both Cuisine and expectations
around Cuisine so this is one of those
serendipitous benefits of having people
involved who think differently than you
do I wouldn't have selected the white
bead groups necessarily but they did and
consumers really liked them this is the
yes
after two generations or two two cycles
of that collection process that I showed
um the visual phenotypes were set so we
knew what we were heading for visually
so that same process didn't quite work
because there weren't colors to sort by
really
so we turned our participatory work
toward flavor
um flavor characterization
um and ended up with some cultivars so
on the low Jasmine side we had snow
globe and Evansville Ember
they're low Jasmine but it turns out
that many commercial cultivars are low G
Osmond that's just kind of what's out
there so they're not really unique in
that aspect but they're unique in the
fact that they were the result of
participatory selection which is
interesting some seed companies
especially those that
um that focus on the story of plant
breeding along with the products of it
one of those companies is fruition seeds
up in Naples really close to here they
serve gardeners and small-scale farmers
and
um
Evansville Ember they took on as part of
their offering but in a different form
um it really wanted to keep segregating
and the the farm uh
constituency kept saying we want a mild
red beet so we're selecting out the
other the other colors but clearly there
were recessive alleles at the two main
color locion beet and then a third one
that confers this
um blocky or dappled or tie-dyed
appearance so it's a really unique
population at this point and they're
letting it segregate because
um they think it's novel and it allows
them to tell a story about how about
plant breeding how populations change
from generation to generation and they
really want to embrace that and I love
that the cultivar is continuing to
evolve after it left my hands
and the hygiasmine side we had three
cultivars come out two Zone selections
one with a few more like uh coral and
magenta tones one selected to be a
little bit lighter and then this white
beet with pink petioles
so these are unique in their flavor
characteristics so they are higher
giosmin than basically every other beat
out there
um they're also unique in appearance so
the Zone beats are different in both
their Vigor and their pigmentation than
the the kyosha beat and the blushing
that bashful is the only pink pretty old
white meat that I know of
um flushing up bashful is being offered
by fruition seeds and Evansville orbit
um has been picked up by high mulling
organic seeds and that is in seed
production
um
so that's exciting to see them going
somewhere
so a range of intellectual property
agreements or Arrangements can be made
in participatory breeding programs the
best solutions for each situation are
highly context dependent
but the general goal is to share with
Farmers both
um money material benefits from the
varieties and also recognition for their
for their work in co-selection
our context was that this work was done
at the University of Wisconsin under a
federal hatch Grant using University
resources so the university Tech
transfer office Wharf had the first
first right to say what they wanted to
do for an intellectual property
Arrangement
um
they declined to PVP or use a plant
variety protection
um
certificate on these beats which is not
uncommon in the vegetable world
um
but they did reserve the right to
license them
uh which is
a common method that they use so in the
case of the farm
model the farmers were easily
identifiable as Steve finkus and Beth
casmar of pp produce
um but they decided they would love to
be recognized for their work but they
don't really they don't care about any
proceeds coming out of this
um
in the Outreach model the people
involved were really too numerous to um
to recognize this substantially and
certainly in terms of monetary payment
but the organization that seen them the
seed to Kitchen collaborative does uh
benefit from the royalties that come
through War so those royalties are
divided basically three ways between UW
Horticulture Department The Graduate
School and the inventors
um which are myself Irwin and Lynne
Mayer Who did the pre-breeding work
you know if you do the math like we
don't get to know
um
how much royalties are that's between
Wharf and the seed company but a fairly
nominal percentage of an overall sale
20 of that divided three ways is going
to be enough to like
get a coffee on
um which is fine I wasn't doing it to
get rich but um
my next participatory plant reading
story takes place north of the Border in
Canada
where I worked with the Canadian organic
vegetable Improvement project for Kenobi
this is a farmer collaborative project
launched in 2018 by the UBC Center for
sustainable Food Systems and the about
to family Initiative for Canadian seed
security which is a nationwide nonprofit
that works with several Regional
non-profits including Farm Folk City or
BC quite a mouthful and quite a network
well the beak breeding project was
driven by me a researcher with some cool
populations and some questions about
beet flavor
Kenobi was driven by farmers and farmer
advocates so the bout initiative had
coalesced farmers who are interested in
seed from both
um a biological and Horticultural
perspective but also an economic uh
political and ethical perspective so
they were very interested in um in seed
security
um
even though there are a lot of
um good seed companies serving organic
growers in North America there is a
border
and uh we've just been reminded recently
that um
various types of disruptions can
um can interrupt Supply chains right and
and borders do matter for that reason so
these folks are interested in building
both the knowledge and the community to
either Source or grow seed that they can
use
um north of the Border where they have
more control over it
um they were particularly interested in
sourcing uh open pollinated varieties
especially to compete with Workhorse
hybrids that they didn't want to rely on
since they can't
um count on them being on the market
from year to year
they're very interested in adaptation
regionally which obviously varies widely
across a place as big as Canada
so their goal was to identify and
develop
um vegetable varieties for for Canadian
Organic Farms so identify meaning
trialing and developing meaning breeding
the program did support a couple of
predatory plant breeding programs one in
sweet pepper one in carrots
but the biggest locusts of grower
engagement was in variety trialing
so or pvt for participatory variety
trialing
it is valuable in its own right in that
it just allows people to see varieties
on their farm when we survey people that
was the number one biggest benefit like
I get to see these things and also get
some Community to trade ideas with about
what we're seeing in our different
places
but getting to know more varieties than
you might if you had to purchase all the
seed yourself
um empowers people to shift varieties
more easily when there is a seed
shortage or when they just want to
diversify their crop offering
it helps them hone their observation
skills so we also heard on surveys that
um
you know I pay attention to what's
happening in my farm but I don't take
notes or like I never I wouldn't
discipline myself to go out every week
or every couple weeks to see how these
things were changing and this got me to
pay attention in a different way
um so that's a value
participatory variety trialing also
serves as an entry point for
participatory plant breeding
um in that it can identify Market niches
where there isn't anything on the market
that's really serving the purpose in a
given region or for a given Market it
can identify germplasm depending on what
you're trialing and it can build those
critical Pharma researcher relationships
which is where these good ideas for
projects uh get started
so variety Trail participants well we
can so there are participants spread all
the way across Canada we had about 60
participants per year some of whom
perfect thank you so much
um
some of them proud local crops in any
given year these were our 2022 trial
crops
oh how do I get back on here
okay
so the structure of Kenobi variety
trials were shaped by balancing the
Nationwide scale of the project with a
particular Regional interests so in the
case of this rutabaga trial we had a
core set of five varieties that everyone
was asked to trial and then they could
add on these other varieties that may be
more
um relevant to one region or another
especially Atlanta Canada has a strong
attachment to rutabaga
um
for ridicul trials we took a different
strategy and grouped the varieties by
days to maturity and Market class so
that say growers in Northern Canada
could only trial the short day varieties
which are the only ones that have a
chance of finishing during their season
we designated the plot size and the
approximate in-row spacing and suggested
planting dates for folks but we asked
them to use their normal their normal
maintenance techniques so these are all
organic farmers but whatever they would
normally do to maintain a crop so we
could get uh the most external validity
or the most uh real world validity
we use the seedlinked trialling platform
for data collection and results
visualization
this helped with uh consistency of data
formatting and just ease of data
collection compared to Google sheet
methods and you know taking a picture of
the clipboard where I took the notes
methods that had been used previously
for the years before I was there uh
participants used intuitive one through
five ratings on various traits
when I got there and found myself
equivocating over the course of a trial
session I thought like I would really
like I would like a rubric to tell me
um what each level is supposed to mean
so we piloted that we put out a rubric
like this
um specifying what levels of Trades
means and and what we're actually trying
to measure with each trait
and we got really good response so on
our season exit survey about 80 of
people uh said that rubric was easy to
use that had helped them in
understanding difference between trait
levels that helped them rate more
consistently among levels and I think
most importantly that they would trust
the data more this year knowing that
everyone had the same reference to use
also in response to a request for more
in-season communication that wasn't an
email because emails are often
overlooked during the busy season I
started making these trial videos from
the field when I would do ratings on my
own plots I would just give examples
this is one I'm giving a two and here's
why
people really liked this they were
conversational my face was dirty but it
was very very real
so after collecting data from
participants we presented results in a
few ways one of the benefits to using
seedlink is that immediately upon the
trials being closed interactive uh
visualizations are available for people
to play with so there are bar charts for
each trait there are these pie charts
that show the number of people who would
or wouldn't grow a certain variety again
there are also photo galleries and
uh comment galleries that are fun to
look through and really kind of flesh
out what might not be captured in
numeric ratings
we also heard from people though that
they wanted a printed report to be able
to refer back to without having to wait
into a website and play with variables
and as a researcher I wanted to subject
these things to some kind of statistical
analysis so we just did simple simple
anovas bar charts heat maps of means
tables and then a little
um simple explanation of uh what
statistical significance means
my
my phrase was the more bling the more
real the thing like the more chance it
is to be a result of Real differences
instead of
variation
okay just a couple examples of results
that we would offer so this was from our
carer trial this past year shows that
all traits accept appearance
um were more positive in
oh no all trades the subject appearance
showed some region effect
um and all the ratings were higher in
western Canada you'll notice that my
environmental variable is a very blunt
instrument of west or east because it
was I tried that in hardiness Zone and
hardiness zone or grouped hardiness
zones didn't show much effect but
um well I guess we did see the the same
ranking of varieties in both West and
East
um we saw no cases of G by e but that of
course doesn't mean that it wasn't there
it means that we only had Farm locations
um we we weren't integrating
environmental variables and that leaves
a lot of questions unanswered and a lot
of insights um
unseen I think so we'll say more about
that later
I like produced a variety somebody
summary for each for each variety this
is an example of the the butter of the
two
uh orthodontist carrot varieties that we
trialed
so taken together the numerical ratings
um we did some
some quantitative yield data with a
subset of Growers
you can you can get an idea of of what
the variety is of how much variation you
might see so a lot of variation in shape
for this Friday Also quite a bit of
variation in flavor ranging from
comments of water nothing flavor to two
is the best tasting care in the trial so
where it worked it really worked but it
was not consistent
um some some of the hybrids were very
consistent as you would you would expect
so we learned several things about
increasing trial completion rates
it's essential for Farmers to have input
into and feel enthusiastic about the
trial goals and the specific varieties
that that they're trialing
contact throughout the season is really
important because everybody's got a back
burn or something and you need to stay
in contact to make sure it's not the
trial as often as possible
um data collection needs to be easy
because people are balancing really busy
lives
and if possible a stipend or some kind
of compensation really helps these
farmers were compensated 300 Canadian
for a completed trial
um and when I did interviews everybody
but one person mentioned unprompted that
they really appreciated the payment
um but that's an end of nine so go
figure I know I know sometimes people
participate in Trials like this for free
it really just depends on what the
context is
from these those interviews I also
gleaned a couple
important points and one are that you
know I was asking all these questions
about like is this information useful to
you and one woman said well you know
it's really whether it's usable rather
than useful because like just because
I've participated in a Radicchio trial
this year doesn't mean I'm really
necessarily in the market for an eqc
next year but if I needed the
information's there I can interpret it
easily and that's the goal I thought
okay that makes sense
um
and also just over and over it hit home
that these trials are part of very busy
lives and farm businesses so we need to
come we need to come humbly with easily
with Easy instructions and um and just
know that people are juggling a lot to
be able to give us
um the the feedback that we're looking
for and that in order to maintain the
relationship we need to reciprocate with
um useful or usable information
um in a timely manner
so I didn't cover the details of the
Kenobi participatory breeding programs
but I just want to highlight a different
option that they used for
commercialization
um these the open source seed initiative
pledge
which is um modeled over after open
source software is any anyone familiar
with Aussie I imagine some folks are
um so basically it's that anyone is uh
permitted to use the seed to grow it to
sell the seed to breed with it but then
any derivatives from that seed also need
to be open source
so this is clear well it's clearly not
appealing to larger commercial interests
oh it's not legally binding
um but the effect has been to create a
pool of Open Source germplasm that is
used by and curated by smaller scale
breeders on Farm breeders who value
um
Regional variety adaptation and
preservation of culturally important uh
cultivars
the osteopledge doesn't preclude
charging royalties
um they have not they're not interested
in that but the kitchen table seat house
um
is offering the Renegade red pepper and
that they were one of the main Pharma
breeders involved the carrots have yet
to meet the market but hopefully they
will
and so now we're in the present what
we're doing on time I'm okay uh yes
so as many of you know the cover crop
reading Network since 2015 has been
reading fall zone legume props legume
cover crops for traits like fall
emergence Winter survival spring Vigor
High biomass hard seed not shattering
pods and just last year we began
breeding cereal Rye specifically for
cover crop purposes
the Network's first uh Harry vetch
variety and the first few pea varieties
winter pea varieties are moving toward
release this year which is exciting
this map shows sites of uh
University and ARS breeding and trialing
sites in purple and pink and then a few
orange orange dots with some on-farm
reading sites
so the Growers at those orange pins
worked with Lisa kissing Cusick who is a
Cornell grad who's now at the ARs in
Wisconsin on a winter pea participatory
reading project from 2016 to 2018.
of the six pea varieties that are
consistently beating checks in our
Advanced line trials or we're actually
farmer selections
so
the method briefly was that each farmer
received five F4 P crosses from the
heiress breeder that we're collaborating
with in Washington
according to the the their breeding
priorities for Peas on their Farm
So the plan was to um
plant them out care for them according
to the farmer's normal practices and
then use a flagging system to select
plants for various traits in each
quadrant of the plot
and and then like the best 10 of of the
plots for
um recombining and another selection the
following year
the weather had different plans
a more parsimonious solution
um
to just freeze everything except for
about 10 of the plants so that was a
much simpler selection process but
really did produce some remarkably
winter hardy lines
um
and the the plan was to bulk seed and
replant the next year for various
reasons that didn't work out but we
still got a really
um we we got an effective results
um
yes so four of them are on our list for
release this year
intellectual property arrangements for
these peas will be guided by the ARs
System since the initial crosses for all
but one of the varieties came from the
ARs breeder Rebecca McGee out in
Washington
so we're hoping to make them public
releases such that a deposit will be
held in grin and will be available
publicly but that we can maintain stock
seed and provide it to seed companies
for trialing Etc
um for the farmer selected lines
two of the farmers who participated run
uh one run the seed company prayer Road
organic seed in North Dakota
right yes
um and then do the farm sells various
farm products out there Farm in
Wisconsin so they are the first right of
refusal for using those varieties on
their farm and then they can choose to
also make them available to other seed
companies
and then they
they also have a right to we we haven't
been aiming to collect royalties on any
of this but if we did they would receive
a share of that
so while our trial Network allows
trialing
um selection and trialing in many
environments there are only a few
locations that are cold enough to really
provide selection pressure or evaluation
pressure for winter survival so to more
thoroughly test it and to introduce
these winter peas or winter peas as
cover crops at all to Farmers
this fall we are planning small scale
winter pea trials with uh we're hoping
to roll out with 60 farmers and we're
hoping to get data back from 40 of them
we'll see how that ratio plays out
we're going to use the seedling platform
that I described previously but we're
going to use a
a model where each farmer will receive a
subset of three varieties from the total
of six along with one consistent check
so this is a variation of the tricot
design which stands for triadic
comparison of three which was proposed
by Jacob Bennett and Lacey knotting
heads a few years ago and it basically
conducts statistical analysis by uh
comparison
by comparing rank among uh among
cultivars instead of by asking Farmers
to to phenotype or things like that
I guess it creates ranks out of
phenotype
but beyond those trials
um this season which will be on a
relatively small scale
how could we use participatory methods
or Community science methods to inform
our work and to expand the reach of
these cultivars that we're producing so
we already have plans for the
participatory work so three of the most
engaged viable Growers from the
participatory P breeding project have
re-engaged they have peas in their
fields this year and we are excited to
see what comes out of it
um
and in addition some ideas are
coalescing in the literature and in
practice around a community science
approach to participatory variety
trialing some of some elements of which
showed up in the Kenobi project and even
the the beat reading project
um so features of this approach are
having multiple points of Entry so not
everybody has to have a full-on
selection experiment at their Farm every
year variety trials especially smaller
scale ones where you maybe only have
three things to compare
um are often easier for Farmers to
commit to they're also even lower Stakes
ways to engage like participatory field
days where Farmers might flag or rate on
a survey
um breeding lines or varieties that they
find particularly appealing
okay
these Community science approaches make
use of um
the ubiquitous digital technology that's
around us so data submission using
various manners of smartphone apps
sometimes soil monitoring devices that
are low cost and and easy and small
um
using modern data science to derive
meaning from Big noisy decentralized
on-farm data
this method was was introduced by Jacob
Bennett's group at seat in 2019 or at
least that's when it was published and
several several recent Studies have
built on this design
one using Bean in Central America
integrated weather data with farmer
observations to discover drivers of
environmental variation and then predict
variety suitability for various regions
in much more precise ways than than
could have been done before a group
including Jean Luke recently published
on the way data-driven decentralized
breeding can improve genomic prediction
you folks worked on wheat
um
because this decentralized model allows
scaling of environmental and management
data to meet the scale of genomic data
which is very interesting
and Holly tupon was also part of the
brand new pnas paper describing how
these data-driven approaches can
incorporate social data
environmental data
um
even economic data so like being able to
reflect some of these values that
surround breeding
um in addition to crop agronomic
performance so these are all very
intriguing ideas and could have
relevance to our work
I'm I'm interested in the Big Data
approaches potentially because we have a
big Network right so we're spread over
all these institutions who each have
connections with groups of farmers that
are already coalesced and already have
interest in in cover crops
so
convening the people is
um is possible
these approach approaches have been used
in the global South thus far but cover
crops provide somewhat of a parallel use
case in the global North in that these
crops are
not as far along the domestication
spectrum and it's common to find both
name varieties and farmer-saved seed or
a variety not stated seed
coexisting in this seed system so so in
that way the situations are similar
um a lot of elements of the network that
we that are not skilled to this level
but in terms of an initial idea I think
it's an initial idea
um and we are parting the tri-cut
technique in our in our smaller scale
trials this season we'll see how that
goes we'll see what responses what we
need to do to you know maximize
engagement
um
and one potential I see is that we're
just starting to work with Rye
um which has a lot more genomic tools
available at this point than our legume
cover crops
um but last point is
however big our data gets and however
refined our predictions can be
we know that um
trust between farmers and researchers is
absolutely essential in determining the
way
um any information that comes out of our
Network and any varieties that come out
of our Network actually meet the land
um
so that's what I've got thank you for
your attention and to all the funders of
all these projects I've presented on
and I'll be happy to take questions
yeah
um well for the Kenobi trials
um
the benefit of working with these
Regional groups is that they each have a
there are five about to initiative
Regional coordinators and three of them
work for these Regional orgs so and they
have a lot of longevity in their
position so they have these trusted
relationships
um
so they were recruited through the
through those networks
um we would give uh you know Season
kickoff webinars for folks who are
signed up or folks folks who are um on
the fence to communicate directly
between like me as the project manager
and the farmers but like the biggest
connections came through the regional
coordinators
um
yeah so like coordinating with groups
that already exist is really essential
because like a network that big is
really
it's not wise to make it hinge on one
person or one coordinator yeah
yeah before the cover crop Network I'm
assuming most farmers who you're having
participated haven't run these mixtures
before making them management
recommendations on how to manage that
bot yeah
I mean I'm newer to the cover crop world
so like
but what I'm gathering is some people
have grown false own cover crops and you
know are
are used to the growing cycle a lot of
people haven't so yeah we'll we'll give
um we'll give sewing recommendations for
sure
um and I don't know we'll have to talk
about how we structure it in terms of
there will be some Regional specificity
so we can like suggest planting dates
for your region but um like what we did
with Kenobi was
you know if you if you learn by
conversation that
a different planning date is better
please do that because like bottom line
is we want them to survive and then like
tell us what you did
um yeah so like enough guidelines that
so that they get a crop to survive if
it's going to you know if winter doesn't
kill it
um but
so that it
so that our results reflect
um
the kind of on-farm management people
could actually do
um yeah
yeah
um very cool talk thanks so much
um something that surprised me I guess
is how much you talked about
intellectual property yeah and I
wondered how soon you begin that
conversation with you start working with
Margaret like ideally right away like
before you agree to do it
um
again it really depends on the context
um but if you're working especially
through an institution like like this
like it's really important to make sure
that you know the tech transfer folks
are on board with what's your what Your
Ideas are are you received from them
what your restrictions might be
um so that you don't get surprised
um because it I think the saddest thing
is to make something cool and then
have it either not get out into the
world or have it get out in a way that
ruptures that relationship between you
and the farmer
um so yeah
as soon as possible
but it's a complex landscape so yeah
yeah related is it something that you're
interested in or is it just like oh my
God I have to do this
um no in fact I those slides are new as
of yesterday because I gave a practice
presentation to
um the CCB lab group and they were like
host but IP and I was like oh God okay
so um
I mean it's a
it's inescapable in the in in the seed
system as it is now we can't pretend it
doesn't exist and um
it's a great place to like have to put
into practice
whatever values we want to bring to this
thing and like and to negotiate
compromises because
um
you know the the Wisconsin beefs like
you know royalties are going back to the
university and people can have various
feelings about that but we just decided
Well it's
funding more grad work and you know I
was indirectly funded by things like
that through the grad school and the
court department so
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu